[Music]
in cakes from hell news submitted by
notice me Joe
you're noticed whoever you are that did
it leave a name we never leave names the
Satanic temple has a plan to troll
anti-gay bakeries I didn't notice a
satanic ax Oh what is Satan istic people
say Satan whatever stations
what about Buddha stations have against
gay people no no no they're trolling
anti-gay people yes
Oh anti I missed the anti my bad my bad
yeah your is that so there's certain
there's different groups I think there's
the Luciferians who are actually they
believe that Satan exists Luciferians
and then there's like Rasta Satan
worshippers and then there's like just
logical non-religious people that claim
to be Satanist to take the title just to
troll people and just to scare people
because they know how that word makes
people so uncomfortable and scary so I'm
thinking this group is the other half
which is the not really believing insane
but then they just take on that name as
a troll group yeah so in the about Us
section of the Satanic temple website it
says the mission of a satanic temple is
to encourage benevolence and empathy
among all people reject tyrannical
Authority advocate advocate political
sorry advocate practical common sense
and justice and be directed by the human
conscious to undertake noble pursuits
guided by the individual will and then
it continues I wanna be a [ __ ] Saint
nents yeah they're actually atheists
like they don't believe in anything but
they take on that name as a satire group
it's kind of like that religion of the
Spaghetti Monster
yeah it's a Pastafarian it's a it's a
satire group against you know excuse me
people institutionalized religion that
doesn't really promote free thinking
yeah
LGBTQ rights advocates are closely
watching the Supreme Court when justices
will decide on an anti-discrimination
law brought against this cake shop so
back in 2012 this case was originally
filed when masterpiece cake shop the
owner of that cake shop cited his
Christian faith when he turned away a
gay couple so they were trying to plan a
wedding and they were trying to get
their wedding cake at that cake shop but
then that's when the owner was like no
I'm not gonna make it for you because
I'm Christian so [ __ ] gays that's
what he said right
maybe so then um so now the Satanic
temple is saying that you know to troll
them a bit they can like gay couples can
request to get a cake I guess a Satan
cake made at these anti-gay bakeries
because legally they can't reject like a
faith and so this is going to the
Christian owner and asking him to make a
devil's cake yeah yeah that's not the
real devil's cakes that one that devil's
food right angel
there's angel cake by Sara Lee yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] that [ __ ] was scary once again
yes looking at a screen cheaters Jordi
took the damn thing off you know oh I
can't see it now so the Satanic temple
co-founder named loosin grieves he
tweeted this photo out Dart
that is dope yeah he said did you know
Baker's can't refuse service to the
Satanic temple because religion is a
protected class
hashtag Satan cakes so so you know that
sign that says like right to refuse
service they can refuse service as long
as it's not based on race and other
things discrimination yeah okay because
like when I saw that board I when I saw
that sign I'm like I never seen it being
used
I've used it oh yeah yeah
now my Lukas what do people have to do
for you to refuse service smell like
[ __ ] now I have clothes on so you
literally tell them sir
you smell like [ __ ] I'm not gonna help
you up uh they're just people who like
cause drama by either just I don't
remember what it was they just annoy
this shot I mean I was just hung Hey
look at that
get out so yeah the point at the same
pretty much and they listen eventually
yeah because there's nothing else they
can do I'm not gonna serve them so
people come in like just button a can
they smell like not like no shoes no
shirt and stuff and they smell like [ __ ]
cuz they're homeless but not not
homeless but they're like crazy people
there's some crazy people that just come
in and it's just mmm
they know what they're doing yeah yeah
so this guy founder of the Satanic
temple and so he's saying that this
whole plan to troll the anti-gay
bakeries it's like a music festival or
something upside down what site I mean
he's resting his hand on something on an
angel with wings wings thank you she
looks like Satan cuz this morning also
looks like a West Hollywood club so he's
saying that hopefully this will prompt a
supreme court to consider either adding
sexual orientation as a protected class
or taking religion away from protected
class status so that's what they're
hoping that's cool
go then maybe because I'm Asian I just
don't understand things like this
because when it comes to business I
don't have to agree with your beliefs or
whatever if you're gonna give me money
and be a good customer whatever I'll do
the best job like providing a service
like it does it has nothing to do with
my morals you know it's like I'm pretty
sure there's a lot of people that are
against pedophiles
but pedophiles need to [ __ ] eat they
need to go and get their car wash they
need to get things done but like are
people saying you're a [ __ ] pedophile
I'm not gonna bake a cake for you yeah
they would not I mean like they don't
want a pedophile cake they just want a
regular cake
they're not you don't like a cake with a
little boy on yeah can I get a cake like
but I think they view it as if that it's
that extreme you know what I mean like
if they knew that this person was a
pedophile even though they don't want a
pedophile cake they're gonna be like no
[ __ ] that am I gonna serve you how about
you guys like since you guys have
barbell would you write about money not
just money uh whatever use what a
pedophile gym member like let's say we
don't even have any kids there I know I
don't know nobody think about it like so
let's say this this guy made a mistake
when he was like 20 years old and then
but now he's like 40 he's married he's
not had one case of pedophilia and he's
working out but then people find out hey
he's a pedophile aside from beating his
ass it's like what can you do he's just
there to lift weights and he's not
bothering anyone
well I would just be a hawk be like
watching you bro yeah not to say like
homosexuality or anything like that is
the same plane as pedophilia it's just
it's just someone that does some did
something that is I guess taboo to
someone else you know like as a business
owner I feel like man I can't really
refuse a lot of people I could only
refuse bad like who would you really
rude or like even at that I kind of like
we still put up with a lot of [ __ ]
like if we had a restaurant or whatever
yeah that's probably the twist right
there
maybe those guys were or whoever they
were guys the girls were really rude to
the bakeshop everybody
yeah yeah maybe they're just really rude
to him and you even know they're gay he
just was refusing their service because
no they wanted a gay cake only wanted a
gig like two husbands or some [ __ ] right
because after a regular cake and just
bought two guys on Amazon I think that's
the point the principle though behind it
is like why should they have to do that
that's not cool that's I guess what I
understand is like for a Chinese game in
they would think of loopholes I know but
oh they don't want to bake a faucet it's
easy we just buy two guys and have them
kissing at the end I know but then
unlike I guess Chinese like like but gay
Chinese people they want to speak up so
there's change that no one else has to
go through it cuz it's America yeah just
go to Chinese bakery no bake anything
yeah see
that's the key if you don't want to be
discriminated go to an Asian business
cuz they'll take money they're open 365
yeah in there 66 360 yet just in case
you thought I was close any holiday they
will not refuse if you've got money they
will not refuse you an Asian cakes are
delicious but [ __ ] it I'm still open
they'll put three guys on that cake for
you they wants you don't make you extra
happy they're like oh you know what just
what extra I put two dick on beside dick
yeah so they're still waiting to see
what the ruling out of this case would
be yeah I guess it makes sense if you're
like very religious and it goes against
your beliefs then if you turn around the
other way then he might feel like his
rights are being infringed because he's
forced to do something he's morally
against but isn't that isn't that weird
because you're opening up a business to
serve a public right like if you wanted
to serve a specific public then just you
should have a bakery that's maybe just
located at a church or something where
it's not open to just the general the
definition of public also changes from
area to area so if you go to like Boston
you know they're like Hilah hella Irish
centric so they're probably thinking all
of my customers are Irish everyone's
Catholic everyone has a certain school
of thought and all it takes is one
person from my two towns away that's
coming in and then it can like really
throw them off it's almost like at JJ
cafe where they serve mainly like
Chinese Vietnamese people and then you
have like one white guy Cole and there
excuse me sir is the eel free-range I
wish you pay yeah we were at what was
that like okiya so we were at that copia
and then the guy won but was it an Asian
guy it was a white guy white guy with
like the Asian girlfriend or something
and then I think it was a dish came with
some sort of like sashimi or something
he's like oh is it farm-fresh is it
something is this a farm fish or is it a
wild caught yeah and the waiter was like
you could really even speaking
she's like no I was the cook it's like
it's like you open up a business in a
certain area and you just it's you don't
you're not against other people coming
but you also don't expect that to happen
yeah like if you were in a small town
that was super duper Christian you kind
of know every customer that comes in you
don't expect like someone different from
LA or New York to come out of nowhere
it's it's just out of the blue right but
that's that I guess it's not just like
they shouldn't they still shouldn't
refuse I don't think yeah if anything he
should have flirted with them more to
give more business see that's the
Chinese mind right there it's like all
of us he's a number one customer man all
the girls go in the back I've had a few
customers that were gay and they would
come in and it would come in regularly
after that and I'm just like okay well
let's just be friendly you know but I
wouldn't really flirt they're into you
so you're just like do they buy a lot of
[ __ ] man you buy a lot of bottles beers
and it's just you know gotta make sales
so what does that say are just our
Asians just like our moral sense is like
really low we don't really stand for
anything thanks for watching guys and
those are our thoughts what are your
thoughts don't forget to comment below
we want to know what you guys are
thinking but don't write anything that
will make it sad or make us mad because
after all we're just kidding news and
we're a very happy channel for the last
video click up here